I want you to take a second and just take a deep breath.
We are going to be talking about evil and pain and suffering.
This may seem like it's just another lesson in the full gamut of lessons and you may be tired.
The year is coming to an end and this is going to take some tenacity to get through.
I want you to pray and I want you to pray for the next four weeks for your students.
Not that you haven't been already, but if it's been hit or miss, I want you to really dial in on prayer this coming week in these next couple of weeks.
Not only that you have students probably that are coming along and maybe are on the verge of making some decisions.
I pray that that is the case.
But you also have just some students that are going to have some significant questions, doubts, pain, hurt brought up these next few weeks.
I want you to be aware of that before we even get started that we're going to dive into some pretty deep and some pretty heavy things over the next couple of weeks.
I want you to be ready for it.
So as you prepare for this week's discussion on evil, I want you to be prayerful for yourself, for your students and for your leaders.
So when we're talking about evil, we're actually talking about two different approaches to how we're talking about evil.
And throughout the next couple of weeks, we're going to look at both of these approaches.
So I want you to be patient because there's two different ways that we can do this.
There is what we call, what I call the philosophical, why can't I spell?
We'll just quote that.
The second is the pastoral approach.
Now, the philosophical approach is sort of academic and the pastoral approach is just what it is.
It's pastoral.
So we're going to look at it from both sides.
So I want you to make sure that you understand that at the starting gate, so you don't jump the gun.
Because it's important that we see it from both sides, but not every student is going to respond to it from both sides, which is why we do it this particular way.
So this first lesson we want students to really understand what evil is.
Evil is the opposite of good.
It's the opposite of God.
And a lot of people will sort of assert that evil is this sort of thing that maybe God created.
That maybe God did something where part of the whole creative universe that there's this force called evil.
And it's the opposite of good and good's a thing and evil's a thing.
Evil is the absence of good.
It's a privation of good.
It's sort of the same thing.
We have darkness, right?
We don't have a measurement for darkness.
The measurement is light.
And darkness is what we call the absence of light.
And the same thing works for cold and heat.
We don't have a measurement for cold.
We have a measurement for the absence of heat.
And that's what we call cold.
We call it the absence of heat.
We call it cold.
It's just how we describe it.
Evil is the same way.
You remove God from the picture.
You remove his goodness from the picture.
And you suddenly have what we would call evil.
And so very philosophically and kind of heady like sort of idea is that evil is this sort of other than God-ness out there that humanity is responsible for.
And we're responsible since the garden because we actually allowed evil to permeate our world because we made the wrong choice.
We made a choice to remove God from the picture.
So evil is a stark reminder that we've lost our way.
That we've looked to ourselves for our own moral compass.
That we've told God that we've got this figured out and we don't need him.
So being the gracious God that he is, you have free will.
You can do what you want.
You can choose to go your own way.
So we did.
And evil was the result of that choice.
So one way I think that your students can really grasp this idea is by the storyteller.
So you want someone that can tell a great story about being lost.
And for some of them might not be too hard to find someone that's been lost but didn't use navigation.
We all have, I don't remember the last time I actually got lost because all I got to do is plug it into here.
But what if you had to navigate by the sun or by a compass?
So you have north and then you have south and you have west and you have east.
How do I know if I need to head east?
How do I know which way is east?
Well, the only way in which I know where east is is if I know where north is.
So the first thing you do when you're lost and you have a compass or you can look at the sun is you figure out where north is.
And once you find what's called magnetic north, then you can orient yourself and you can figure out every other direction.
Well, imagine if the compass just kept being pointed back to you.
What would you do? You'd just be walking in circles trying to figure out where you're supposed to go.
You'd never be able to find east or west or south for that matter.
It has to be something external of you, something that's not you to do that.
So God serves as that moral compass.
So what that leads us to conclude, and this is where the philosophical piece comes in,
is the very fact that evil exists suggests that God exists.
Think of it this way.
If there is no good, then there is no evil.
If there's no God, there's no good.
If there's no good, there's no evil.
Because if there's no good, then there's no evil.
That means there's nothing to compare it to.
The only way in which we understand what evil is is because we have good because we can look at evil and go,
that's not good.
So if that doesn't exist, then God doesn't exist.
But there is evil.
Therefore, there's good.
Therefore, there's the standard to which we compare good and evil to.
Therefore, God exists is kind of how that works.
Hopefully that made sense.
So from a philosophical standpoint, the very existence of evil suggests that God exists.
Because we have a standard to which we can understand what evil actually is.
Okay, so small group time.
You're going to get questions.
It's going to get real, real fast.
So this is the point where students are going to start bringing up probably a load of questions on you,
like, well, why does God allow suffering?
Why does God allow good people to suffer?
Why do bad things happen to good people?
And any other variation of the question that basically says, why is there evil in suffering?
Some of it you can probably answer as it relates to evil specifically.
Some of it you may want to table.
But be careful how you table a question.
Make sure you write it down.
Write it in your leader's guide, your discussion guide, or wherever you have to.
So you can come back to it so you don't ignore the question.
But there's going to be a lot of questions.
And if you're not getting a lot of questions, your students still have the questions.
So I would suggest posing them yourself.
Ask them the questions that they're probably asking you.
So if no one says, why has God allowed suffering?
Or why has God allowed good people to suffer?
Why has God allowed a child to die?
Why has God allowed a lot of things that we kind of look at and go, oh my gosh,
what an injustice, what a terrible thing?
You ask it and see what they think.
But be ready because this is going to start getting very, very personal
and very deep for some students,
especially if they have experienced any kind of evil or suffering in their lives.